all
right we are live hello Brandon welcome
to the show yeah it's good to be here
yes this is going to be really fun yeah
yeah I'm excited talking about
integrated somatic inquiry yeah MH and
the simulation and the simulation
exactly the holographic Universe
MH oh oh yeah I really enjoyed our
connecting even just leading up to this
it's just like you know you have a
certain you Precision in the way that
you speak about like liberating
contractions which I really like a lot
why don't um why don't we talk about
that and um its relation to kind of the
holographic universe so yeah we
apparently contract and then we
apparently heal and expand so take us
that's so great yeah there's so many
directions I could take it but just what
first comes is
like in a
contracted State we not not here we're
not we're not present we're in
psychological time and by definition
there's a like a projection you could
say of the The Matrix or the simulation
from the now into past and future and
it's we can call it suffering right and
we'll mistake our life for the
projection of our life and typically
it's like having a a painful past event
that's not integrated which means it's
suppressed and repressed
oh
and so talk about ways to like unearth
that especially it's rampant in kind of
like the new age world where it's like I
had one Spiritual Awakening all my
trauma is done you know I'm a healed and
um I'm whatever the claim is it's like
that's to me is like the the sure sign
they have a lot of work to do but the so
it's like these experiences that go un
integrated that get repressed that then
become um you could say beneath our
conscious mind are like it's like
driving in a car and consistently
looking in the rearview mirror trying to
avoid a a crash that you previously
experienced and by continuing to drive
and staring in the rear view mirror
you're setting yourself up to crash and
repeat and repeat it and an entire
Narrative of who you are based on your
past and based on avoiding a future
which is guilt and anxiety becomes the
norm and people think their way out is
money is sex is a relationship a
substance it's some material solution to
get out of an immaterial problem and
that furthers the Trap and the
powerlessness and
so yeah isi integrated sematic inquiry
is it's not about acquiring anything
it's not about learning anything it's
not about finding a solution to a
problem it's about dissolving the
validity of the problem nice yeah and in
the absence of that is everything we're
looking for in the material in the
outcome in the money yeah and
um in the absence of looking for it you
find it it's like as soon as I look for
it I leave it and so I don't need to
find it no one needs to get better at
finding success happiness or whatever it
might be
but to
question the spell that says this is
your way to Freedom which by definition
means you're not free as you are right
and so we go into not just what's
happening in the conscious mind but into
the unconscious narratives that always
say it's like in the non-d Dual world
for example our journey to God is this
wow I realized the eye that I've been
referring to isn't this small self
doesn't actually exist I can't find it
and the the absence of that is
everything I'm looking for and that's I
remember rert Spyro saying this that's
chapter one of the book and that's the
journey to God the journey in God is the
integration that is endless and can
always become more precise more
authentic more loving more bold whatever
it needs to look like
yeah so the damn I loved uh at the very
beginning when there was that like the
Contra the contraction itself solidifies
everything including uh that there's an
actual past that there's an actual
future completely takes us out of the
Bliss and the peace that underlies
everything already and the freedom that
underlies everything already and then
through that uh through that solidity
then is uh the desire to be unsolid or
to dissolve that solidity to heal to do
this inquiry into the Soma and and I
love the the analogy too it's like we
it's just no way basically the only
thing that's happening is either we're
CH either we're choosing to
repress or we're not MH yeah yeah either
we're choosing to stay limited or we
want
unlimitedness so
badh and what's tricky about the
repression is to to be consciously A
Ware that you're repressing isn't uh
that's not part of the repression
experience you're not aware that you're
choosing it there's an automatic
reaction that you deem normal who you
are um helpful um there's some
relationship to it that goes why would I
it's the last thing you would look at to
change because it's so buried that it's
like we can say we're choosing it but
it's it's it's like the way that we we
translate the unconscious automatically
choosing it feels like there's no choice
but if we zoom out and we look at it as
an unconscious choice we can still see
it as a choice just to frame it and like
oh we're all Sovereign we're all
choosing on certain levels it's just our
biology can literally run the show
whether we want it to or not right right
the energetic contraction runs the body
at that point um and
the that's this this is why like uh you
see all those like little kids that are
like uh I don't know scared of something
and then like there's like the exposure
therapy or even adults that have had a
trauma and then there's exposure therapy
and that kind of thing but like like a
huge part of it is just like the
fearlessness of going into whatever the
pain ish and like and just seeing it as
a sensation seeing it as a texture right
yeah yeah something to um that is
actually a gift it's like a it's a
diamond you know and it's actually where
your wisdom is yeah yeah I love that
part of it too so then that like kind of
can excite like what happens if I you
know make that call and apologize or
what happens if I you know heal within
me that hatred that I have for my family
member or whatever
it how how much more free mhm is my
heart yeah yeah and it's like on the
surface especially in the more new Agy
spirituality it's not sexy on the
surface it's like no do plant medicine
or you know um some ceremony or ritual
and all these things and that's great
and what's your relationship like with
your parents and your friends and like
that's your immediate curriculum because
it's it's the the first reflection
outside of your body that you know
you're not dealing with like it's going
to hit you emotionally where there's
contraction then it's going to hit you
in symptoms and then if you're still not
and usually even quicker than this but
if you're not dealing with it all of
your relationships are going to become a
a mirror image of that contraction and
it's so so it's like yes the way through
is always
apparent and it's it's what's arising
right now that would that feels like
it's keeping you from the truth or from
freedom and like you said moving right
through it I had this experience where
moving through repressed anger like we
mentioned where I really let myself be
angry and but not doing anything with it
I think sometimes it's like the only way
to repress your anger is to beat
something up and it's like okay that you
can energy can be moved and it can be
embraced that way sure but embracing
energy doesn't it doesn't uh require a
certain movement of the body if that was
the case then people that were paralyzed
couldn't move anger and they'd be
actually limited it it'd be because of
their body so it's not Universal that
you need to do something right to allow
transmutation to happen it's like you're
stepping out of the way of resistance
towards that emotion and it's
transmuting itself right it's like they
say in Buddhism reality is self-
liberating so it's like you're letting
the The Liberation happen same thing
they say in Christianity it's like my
you know they uh Jesus forgave all of my
sins he took my sins away from me
they're referring to the same thing
yeah and so I I remember this time I was
so angry so beautiful as you said that
there was a balloons animation that came
up on the on the cuz you did that oh
that's so I just noticed that's a new
update that was happening yesterday with
my clients I would do like something and
like a thumbs up would happen I'm like
okay like zoom we're vibing right
[Laughter]
now um it was great timing with the
reality self- liberating itself and also
just taking the sins away like yeah yeah
celebration celebration yeah good
news so yeah I was I just I just went
right into the I was like overflowing
with anger my my reaction was like I
have to do something with this which is
a subtle resistance to it it says this
has to move this has to change it's like
the same thing as uh people preaching
about patience which is your ability to
wait for something better which is
slavery it's it's enslavement just be
more patient just wait for something
better than this it's the same thing so
versus presence right so I was like okay
anger's here and I just went I sat
straight down I was pacing back and
forth I sat straight down I just went
right into it I just all of my attention
on anger With No Agenda and immediately
the Seas inside of me like my the Sea of
emotion
opened and it was just Bliss and
absolute certainty which was an
interesting thing to experience where it
was like I know what's at the center of
the things we fear because I coming from
an anger repressor I don't want to go
into anger like that's scary you know as
a kid my parents my dad like there's
angry people and and I can't do that
it's it's scary it hurts people right so
to go right into that was was to allow
that version of me to die and that's why
it feels so scary but in that death is
this oh just this like steing of the
water and this this Freedom yeah and um
it was such a powerful moment and you
know before that I've had many times
where it's like oh I don't have anger
problems I'm liberated conscious mind
and then the perfect thing happens to
bring it to the surface and it's like oh
I have no idea what's actually under the
surface this is why any phrase that
implies time is false I'm always
liberated and I always will be you know
it's like you start to create time in
that moment it's like you can't know
what's in your body until it's there any
phrase that implies time is false
yeah yeah it's a trap it's so
good oh okay you going
[Laughter]
here um but yeah it just it just again
it's like it speaks
to the grounded it's like what I I want
to call it like grounded spirituality or
just telling the truth which
is I can't
know I can't know what is going to
unfold and so in the absence of claiming
to be anything for value for whatever it
might be I'm just open to experience and
in that openness it there's going to be
times where I'm absolutely terrified and
contracted right and it's not it's like
we're not here to avoid those moments
it's like actually the more that I can
let those moments in the more freedom
there is for me yes and I will attract
situations and circumstances to bring
that up because life wants to liberate
me it's like that is the evolutionary
impulse that's the movement towards
order I have to attract the chaos
necessary like a puzzle piece that fits
perfectly with me to give me an
opportunity to be liberated or not and
that's like the inherent choice that we
have or feels like a choice in that
moment but it's just the
translation of feeling vast like when
you when you feel vast you feel like you
have unlimited Choice yeah yeah and uh
to bring that to those moments is is the
work nice yeah it's like the the Mastery
the energy Mastery of when things
contract don't avoid don't escape don't
anything just like like allow and be
with and like process metabolize
alchemize all those
things and um uh because you know it's
just quote a temporary sensation you you
know
that you know that it's a lesson like
you know that it's a learning you know
that you know on the on the other side
is greater Mastery greater wisdom and um
getting really good at that is like any
contraction can be expanded for myself
and for anyone that I in interface with
there's no limit on Consciousness that
can not be broken that cannot be
alchemized right every single one like
that's so empowering yeah yeah and if
that becomes it's like that's a great
definition of success for people is can
I be with this yeah and it's like that's
my only job yeah yeah is to to question
and to feel or we could say to alchemize
what's in the way of me being with this
there's actually nothing more that I
want yeah no one nice it's like they
want a million dollars so they can
finally be with their life as it is yeah
and and stop the effort it's like the
Buddha said even a blink is too much
effort even one blink of the eye is too
much effort for the Buddha yeah it's
like I'm not efforting to become
anything yeah right but it's like for
that to be authentic I actually have to
acknowledge all the places I still
believe I do
need X need to become this need that and
and that's um humility damn that's so
powerful yeah yeah like leaving oneself
because oneself is not enough MH and
then getting whatever is thought that
will make it be okay MH uh
versus as long as the basic needs are
met like that component is obviously so
crucial like as long as the basic needs
are met there's really really
everything's an inner job yeah and up to
this point everyone on the planet that's
alive have had their basic needs met
enough to be alive right you know and
that's that's another it's like right
the the you can be starving and not
mentally and emotionally suffering
through like a practice like inquiry
where it's like I'm very hungry that's
actually that's a sensation it's like
when I did I did a 4-day fast in the
desert and I was like there was times I
was extreme extr hungry and that can
either lead to a story that mind puts on
top of it that I believe that creates
suffering or it could just be completely
meeting that sensation which usually
lessens the sensation or completely
changes and transforms the sensation and
so it's
like what I need is what is what I want
is usually never what is right right but
I like my wants are here to actually
bring me back to what I need and what I
need is what I have and that's the
ultimate gratitude to land on right cuz
then you go oh I have everything I need
right now the the lack of what I need
only exists in a future and a past yeah
and that's not in reality that's just as
real as saying you know tomorrow there
might be a unicorn that shows up on my
front lawn like I'm going to hold on to
that belief that's just as true as well
I'll probably wake up tomorrow they're
both just thoughts right so it's
like without in the absence of that I
can't have a need unmet yeah I really
can't even if I'm starving and I'm this
close to death right I might say okay my
need is unmet right when I die but death
isn't an experience it's not like I'm
okay I'm dying now no I'm in this form
then I'm in another form it's the same
way we have deep sleep right it's like I
don't experience deep sleep I don't
remember it the falling asleep and the
waking up are in the same moment
experientially you know it's like as
soon as you fall asleep you kind of you
wake up I wonder how long I slept for
and you don't remember the moment you
fell asleep you remember moments
previous to falling asleep so you
actually don't
experience deep sleep which is the
absence of conscious awareness look at
the dog so sweet teup such a sweet
hi
yeah and the point there is just that
we so cute um that
we
um the same
way that it's to completely valid to
experience our needs not being met for
the sake of questioning that which we
need to be at peace in this moment which
wouldn't can't wouldn't take us away
from
eating from drinking water it's not
going to take us away from the Practical
things it's just going to remove the
layer of suffering we stack on top of it
which really just gives us access to be
more creative and resourceful in the
midst
of something that's challenging the body
right oh it's so good
so
so so basically everything is that's
being liberated are just things that
have been stacked on top
of and if we think of like where did
this stacking start we can't there's no
cause we can't find oh it's my this
ancestor it's this moment if we want to
like go into time it's the big bang you
know it just goes all the way back so
when you look for like someone to blame
there's not it's just life yeah and so
it's like okay I'm the intended result
of you know 13 point something billion
years of movement and I can't say this
one thing or that one thing is the cause
of my suffering or the cause of my
trauma yeah but it it doesn't take away
from working with memories and this is
what I do in with clients because back
to the holographic nature of reality and
that one slice that one
frame it contains the whole yeah so so
you can access all the information you
need based on one specific pattern that
may in be you know the result of
billions of years but the way that it
played out in that moment has all of the
information of what's going on in that
individual psyche and the repressed
emotion that if liberated would render
that pattern and its repetition obsolete
yeah um simply because you're not
invested in it as a source of safety or
love anymore right so we still use we
still use time
to dissolve time yeah so it's like let
me let's go to this memory and see why
it makes sense to a young part of your
psyche that needs to hold on to it
there's something some need it's like
this book called existential Kink it
talks about loving our shadows and
getting off on our own drama and like oh
I love the drama and I need this cuz the
struggle and the you know like humans
and so we could still find why
why the psyche holds on and it's always
for a sense of safety protection love
right that's been confused for safety
protection and love and when they find
that and they make the the unconscious
conscious that splitting in the mind is
is no longer and it just becomes
irrelevant and it's like the
phrase forgive but don't forget it's
actually forgive and do forget we we we
forget get what we no longer need brain
goes why would I hold on to this so bad
to cling on to something that's already
even been healed and metabolized yeah
sometimes I get that reflection it's
such a funny one it's like bro like
you're done with this like what are you
doing are you coming back yeah what you
doing here usually because it has a
message it's like you're not done with
me or you know cuz what I what the the
deeper holographic perspective is like
I'm Pro in that version of the past
right now based on as a reflection of my
state of being right now I'm
magnetizing certain versions of my past
and the past is a dynamically changing
structure it's not linear so as I shift
my past my future shifts and that might
seem like reemerging Memories new
memories different perspectives on
memories but it's all a reflection of my
state of being in the now I'm going to
access memory as a reflection of that
state and I'm going to project a type of
future as an extension of that state and
the future I'm going to project is going
to feel like excitement and inspiration
for unlimited possibility yeah if I'm in
an open State yeah and if I'm contracted
it's going to feel like avoiding anxiety
yes yes
nice I love um with cleanup like I love
going into the the holographic frames
like that's such a good way to such a
poignant way to describe what it's like
to uh go somewhere that feels like
there's a contraction of light and sort
of in this timeline within the body in
the cellular memory itself and and uh
and fearlessly go into it like that's
like I think that that's probably like
one's own like claim of safety like
imperturbable safety you know if that is
like claimed like fully like I am that
MH then it's like everything's allowed
you know like let's go um so then that
what like what's a classic like fear
avoidance or anxious response and no no
no no let me
go that is no longer because it's like
excitement around the Mastery for the
wisdoms
for um for not having to repeat the
patterns later mhhm to be more free mhm
yeah yeah yeah yeah well
said yeah oh it's it's it's funny like
seeing it as a like an an advertisement
that kind of pops up you know it's just
like like there's I mean and you become
energetically masterful enough to be
able to determine like when things are
quote um like
[Music]
uh it's just so much here it's so funny
I'm sure you get this you probably get
this a lot you get like popups you know
for like a client that might not
actually be ripe or something like that
and you know you've went down this path
before where you invite the client in
for a session even though you know
they're not ripe or whatever and then
the whole hour is like nothing
changes
so it's just like
discernment you know
ripeness like ripeness for
transformation yeah for healing for this
work for
um and like a surrendering of trying to
morph reality through the external
Acquisitions of endless sorts yeah it's
like okay fine like it's okay so going
to more from here yeah Yeah Yeah well
yeah you're you're speaking of I've used
these terms before going from an outside
in approach versus an inside out
approach and we're still like speaking
in dualistic terms but it's helpful
because
it's well if I'm not ready I have to go
outside in I have to look for something
outside of myself because it's so scary
to look within and face the things that
six seven 8-year-old me made a decision
at one point not going to ever do that
again don't know how to process this and
I'd rather wear a mask and become some
Persona than feel this and and die yeah
because it in a trauma response in the
the the cell danger response in a what's
called a DHS which is a dirk Hammer
syndrome which is a German new medicine
term it talks about being caught off
guard um isolated and completely
overwhelmed and when that hits all at
the same time there's an adaptation that
happens in the brain goes this is
overwhelming we need to adapt and help
the organism survive and that can be
from something physical happens all the
time it's like if you driving in the car
and a car is coming at you and you have
this split second thing before it even
started cuz your subconscious is so
tuned in and Powerful it's already
adapting you it might turn on more cells
in your lungs so you can breathe better
it might you know um start pupil dilate
pupil dilate it might start to reinforce
your skin and like create more cells on
your skin to guard you and then the next
day you might have some pimples or the
next day you might have um you know some
mucus to then get rid of those extra
cells that you no longer need and it's
happening it's turning on and turning
off just like that you know let's say in
that physical
context but because our body doesn't
know the difference between what's
happening in imagination and mind and
physical reality you can be in a
metaphoric car
crash just first thing waking up in the
morning because because of some
unprocessed integrated thing that gets
triggered and that adaptation can turn
on and that over time is what chronic
disease is it's the continuous turning
on not resolving slowly coping or
repressing turning back on and you're
going in and out of healing and
adaptation and healing and adaptation
and you're not sustaining the healed
State on a biological level right and so
I think the new paradigm
of medicine what we're going to see is
just a reflection of the understanding
that's it's all mind yeah it's another
way of saying Consciousness and that if
we're looking for cause and effect we
have to put them in their correct places
which is inside Inside the Mind Right
the consciousness of the individual both
cause and effect yeah and when we do
that there's a comp total shift in our
orientation towards life because no
longer are we at the effect of life the
life is not affecting us it's it's
reflecting us yeah right so it's like
ah I'm I'm
invited to see what I'm
causing suffering resistance whatever it
might be when this thing seemingly is
the cause of it it's actually revealing
an internal cause yeah and when I I use
it that way I start to play the game of
the game you know like the game of life
we sold is work for 40 years external
external yeah make money you know
American Dream have a family and then
you'll be H retire one day then you'll
be
happy and like you said it's external
it's about acquiring
something and now if you look at the
that process there there's no emphasis
on the process it's all about end result
game of the game isn't what am I getting
it's who am I being now yeah in
relationship to what's happening yeah
and if that becomes my number one value
in life not to get not to just that as
my number one I start I enter the game
of the game and my only goal is can I be
with reality as it is number one goal of
game is frequency one's own frequency
one's own Freedom internally at the
cause of the Hologram right where
there's just like Joy overflowing and
like able to serve mhm because of that
healed inside yeah um is so good and
then like timelessness as a natural I
like I love the analogies you were using
with with athletes also that's just such
a spot on because it's such a or
musicians or whatever there's no sense
of self right it's just a
waterfall of shooting or of you know
whatever it is yeah it's the it's the
the you that is experiencing the
inspiration isn't there it's just
inspiration nice it's just passion and
in that there it's it is self fulfilling
yes yes it doesn't lead to fulfillment
it's self-fulfilling very cool and
self-perpetuating the more you're
passionate about passion the more it
snowballs onto of itself and it the the
means is the end yeah and so when the
means is the end it's like what I'm
looking for has to be here now and if
I'm under the illusion it's not that's
my work nice beautiful yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly oh that's so good basically
so then the work is if something doesn't
feel Timeless and free and ignited as
self- passionate then that's where the
work is absolutely because you're going
to be under some spell of obligation
right and where there's obligation
there's guilt right and where there's
the guilt there's past and where there's
a guilty past there's an anxious future
yes yes so it just takes us right back
into that right and so you can't be
absolutely living in truth in that
moment now it doesn't mean it's like
like I'll give you an example if I um
gave my word to someone say hey I'm
going to do this for you and then in
that process I discovered oh this is not
what I want to do there's two paths you
can take you can be honest about it say
actually this isn't true you know I'm
actually there's no part of me that's
excited about this something is
genuinely changed within me to where I'm
a different version of me than the one
that originally made this commitment
right and so you're more committed to
the truth than you are to an arbitrary
commitment right and that's can be very
relieving for the other person because
they're going I don't want someone that
doesn't want to create this for me or
team up with me in this way so that's
going to create space for them right
number one number two is they're not on
the same wavelength as
you and there's a version like where you
can speak that truth but as a compassion
concession do what you said you were
going to do because it might be the path
of least resistance for everyone
involved and it's like then it's like
can I do this but do it in a way that
does excite me right can I can I change
my experience of the task in a way that
actually works for me and so often we
can do that we're that we're that free
and flexible you know it's not just the
inherent task that either creates
excitement or passion it's really who
being within it and a lot of times just
the coming back to the truth and then
making a choice not from obligation
relieves us from you know the anxiety
the pressure or whatever it may be yes
and so it's not like it's so good cuz a
lot of people will take this teaching of
excitement inspiration moving in the
direction of Truth and let ego hijack it
and as soon as they are committed to
someone and it gets sticky go it's just
not my truth my truth is to leave and
what they're really saying is I'm afraid
right right yeah and it's like if
there's fear truth is hidden yeah yeah
you can't right see you don't have
Vision you have sight you don't have
Vision when you're in fear so you can't
say I know this is not true for me if
there's fear simultaneously because
they're not coexisting you're either in
fear or not and so it's
like making all choices from that place
of neutrality and not riding the high or
low of an emotion
nice
is yeah you know this like kind of stoic
neutral sober yes path yes yes nice nice
I love that and that's that feels like a
great way to um marry the the masculine
spaciousness uh neutrality with the kind
of feminine sensuality of every
everything anything totally totally yeah
yeah oh I love that U cuz it's just it's
so nice when it's like felt balanced
inside it's almost like neutrality is
sensuality ink
orh and it's like it's the balancer yeah
you know cuz you're not on a extreme
polarity of anything
it's like you've come to the third to
the middle way right and in that it's
like something will spontaneously arise
through me and that's true whatever that
is exactly and how do I know it's true
because I have this sense of of choice
which is always that's the opposite of
feeling like a victim all a victim is is
I don't believe I have a choice it's the
illusion of the the the Cho our choice
being taken away from us and in that
feeling limited and contracted in the
absence of that it's like I feel so
expansive and then we translate that we
go I have so many choices and options I
could do I could be anything so like in
that free space of ins
inspiration um whatever arises on behalf
of it isn't arising on behalf of ego
it's not arising on behalf of separate
self it's arising on behalf of Life yeah
and going this is something that only
you can bring through and the setup is
you're just you you you just so happen
are going you're going to love it like
it's built into you having absolute
fulfillment to say yes to that that's
just how it's set
up and that's
great yeah like yeah everything that's
flowing becomes absolute fulfillment and
it
is before there was ever one that was um
we I'm I'm watching I got
you um yeah before there was ever a
contraction that started to limit or to
hijack or manipulate or control or any
of those things um which has been such a
beautiful process in a way of
unlimiting unlimited
unlimiti oh um because then the joy is
the natural Fountain like the the peace
the sensuality all of those things are
just a natural Fountain but that it's
all kind of TW nodded up twisted up in
all kinds of bodily cellular psychotic
places and then it's like oh my gosh you
know teacher help me right yeah
yeah religious Master you know whatever
help
me and it's just it's also super
important to like be Discerning about
all of that too cuz there's all kinds of
like shadowy stuff that happens within
that totally and so then um it's
like uh identifying the most rapid
Pathways for
Liberation for healing for expanding the
contractions and
then uh ceasing the sing afterward so
like now we come as equals MH right so
if I need to if I need to suck the tit a
little bit to get what I need to heal
what I need right but then you know
you're always punching me back into my
my freedom my sovereignty my wholeness
and I'm like oh [__] oh okay all right
you know after some years of work or
whatnot like boom now it's like you can
turn around and become the the tit
yourself yeah yeah and help suckling on
your own
tee and what I love about that too is
like this happen this comes up a lot
with my clients like at one
point they might say something like yeah
this person like I saw this person and
they healed the helped me heal this or
healed this thing in me or there's some
attributing to the other person for
their healing and it's not that we can't
use language to like give appreciation
for our experience cuz it's yeah my
experience was maybe I sat down with
someone something was said it hit me
like a ton of bricks and I go I couldn't
have had that experience without the
other person but the moment the the ego
grabs a hold of that and goes well
that's how you heal now you find the
people with the things that you need get
it from them as if it's like you can
just reach into them grab the healing
and then put it in you where you need it
right like hey if if that was the case
it's like here take just it's in this
basket here's your healing just take
that and and consume it drink this you
know it's like we would all just be
drinking the same healing juice if that
was the case so it's the questioning of
has have I ever actually given my power
away not the I need to take my power
back from a guru but did I actually give
it away in the first place or was it my
believing yes and thinking and then
subsequent feeling that generated my
entire experience and they were a
standin they were permission exactly and
so they actually can't like it's a it's
a fallacy to say someone can take my
power yeah because I'm using my power to
create yes to create that Dynamic yes
yes exactly so the whole actual
demonstration was a demonstration of
your power yes just being filtered
through a more
limited point of view yeah the you
needing the experience or the lesson of
quote
Outsourcing and being reflected back
hopefully purely that hey you're
Outsourcing exactly yeah it's like eart
to said he said the what's useful about
suffering is to suffer Until you realize
it's no longer useful yeah and that's
great and for me you know I I welcome
all kinds of mentorship I
I have a men's group that I co-lead and
it's
like yeah I realize I have an
unconscious mind that I can't always see
and others because they're not me can
see what I can't see and so the openness
to just see me yeah exactly see what
maybe I don't see the defenselessness
which is perfect it's like there's a
freedom in that right and that's that's
where this work has taken me it's not
taken me to the freedom of
defenselessness oh that's such a good
one yeah just like freedom of
vulnerability but I but I like
defenselessness yeah yeah it's like
we're all one Consciousness un
unlimiting itself right exactly and in
the defenselessness it's like someone
might say yeah I don't trust you because
of this and if your response is yes it's
not what it's like I'm going to look at
that yeah yeah like I'm a I'm
energetically open to that being
absolutely true right what are you
defending right where's there's no
suffering even if there's contraction
defending just an idea or a thought or
right because the the moment you go into
defense you crystallize the separate
self it's like now I'm this one being
attacked by you and like there's there's
the fight right there but if it's
like if there's no defense there's just
then either that's bringing
unconsciousness to the surface and I'm
in contraction with you in which case I
want that like I want to know where I'm
contracted yeah exactly right or I
defend it and I fight for the limitation
God it's so good to hear it this way
it's like we're all on teams to expand
contractions and to stop defending
yeah
our those contractions yeah and if
that's our conscious agreed context for
relationships that's really cool yeah
because it's kind of like hey like where
why are we in relationship chemistry fun
joy love all these things great yeah and
it's a context for this kind of
integration right that I I'm never going
to be able to genuinely say again in
time that I'm just done with I don't
need to say that yeah exactly yeah you
know I'm just open to it never ending ex
which and when I'm open to that I do
feel a sense of right now it's like the
it's like already free and yet always
unlimiting itself right right so and
then like that's like the beauty of the
school or the Dojo or whatever however
you want to call it it's like it's
always like breaking limits always here
there everywhere like and like free Free
People Free People Free People free
Consciousness free Consciousness
abundance joy for all like let's go
build the new world let's have fun let's
children be born into perfect harmony
with nature and Technology all this kind
of stuff and um like that's kind of also
this like it's you can't transcend and
go somewhere right because that is this
they're the same thing so so that's why
it's like this active excitement about
existence about relativity about love
dancing with itself about yeah yeah yeah
and it's also why things like War when
we see atrocity there's this innate kind
of Rage response because we we see a
violation of Truth yeah and we we know
it's not true because all of us deeply
know who we are what what we are we have
this deep intuition of wait I don't
think I'm just this body I don't think
this is random and we might be so
steeped in denial that we can't admit
that to ourselves yet but most of us
have this intuition that I'm greater
than this and that sense in our body is
the yearning to be free yeah and so when
then we see the opposite of that
extreme
oppression violation of you know all
kinds of Human Rights human rights just
genocide what we're seeing right now in
the Middle East like you see that and
you go this
affirms the opposite of what's true
exactly this is you could say Lucifer
it's like the inversion of truth it's
completely upside down and so it
evokes I'll just this is I think this is
from the Bible it evokes God's will
Within me Tyrant tyranny evokes God's
will within me so it's like the will of
God is to be a stand for
truth you could say that's what it looks
like in action to know it looks like
peace but in action it's like I'm making
a stand for it I'm demonstrating it
because there's no there's nothing
between my knowing of it and my doing of
it because those are synonymous they're
the same so when I'm actually standing
for it I'm demonstrating and teaching
it's my Ministry I'm teaching the truth
and we all have a unique way of doing
that could be art it could be
fundraisers it could be whatever it
might be that arises spontaneously in
that state of
truth I don't remember where I was going
with that but oh gosh that's that's so
perfect but the war the war again it
it's it's a mass it's like a mass
permission slip to remember what's true
yeah and then to have an opportunity to
stand for it or not and it's like that
that's a test to past when enough people
stand for the truth in the face of
what's not true we're completely
accelerating this Awakening process yes
on a on a mass scale yeah and so equal
and opposite reaction the greatest
atrocity holds the key to greatest
fulfillment absolutely yeah yeah yeah oh
my gosh there's so many good ways to to
play with this
um wow
the the Stillness and the peace and the
freedom The Emptiness is not a ground
it's not a place to go and transcend
into or hide from relativity right um
and it's so beautiful when um one fully
kind of um embodies this uh what what
you were saying like tyranny in a way it
triggers God's will for uh transforming
Injustice yeah yeah into Freedom love
unity abundance all these things
and I just like one of my favorite
things is like recently has
been all of the quote like we've been
calling it like spiritual [__] it's kind
of like this archetype of just like uh
transcended and like like yeah the
bypass yeah yeah yeah and like and like
just like taking them by the genital and
like bringing them into Gaza you know
bringing them into the middle of where
there's human rights violations there's
no basic needs being met people are
suffering limbs are cut off bombs are
dropped all this kind of stuff because
it can't live there that can't live
there so it it auto integrates right
it's forced to see what it's actually up
against in terms of healing separation
wounds trauma multi-generational
traumas of border conflicts
and and so when you look and you see
like two people that are literally from
the same land that have have had an
imaginary border drawn between them that
now hate each other right that happens
everywhere around the world but that's
where all your work
ish that's where all the work is
like it's it's not
like oh it's so good there's nothing mhm
is nothing yeah yeah and it's like yeah
that is this so great like yeah let's
let's alchemize like the root like your
own root chakra itself is the center of
the Earth where all of the knot of
seeing separation and seeing and feeling
pains and protection and wounding and
hoarding and all kinds of things like
that's where all of the work is and if
you're actually quote Unlimited
Consciousness
then you would want to Swan Dive Into
liberating all the limits because you
came here to eat those limits right yeah
yeah like that's what you were saying
earlier the fearlessness yeah it's like
the spiritual
bypasser is a coward you know by default
and it's not wrong or bad it's just the
I don't want to go to war or I don't
want to stand for something where my
personal life existence self may be
threatened so there there can't be a
selflessness because there's so much
concern with the self so no I'm not
going to do that but the reason I'm not
going to do that is because it's not
spiritual right so that's the
justification to keep the fear alive and
then to keep the image of no but it's
spiritual and if I believe it hard
enough I don't have to actually look at
the fear where in truth the more
spiritual thing to do I'll just give
this as an example it's like if someone
in your backyard right now if there's an
old lady in her purse is getting stolen
it would be to go stop that yeah it go
be to interrupt the conflict it's like
oh that's just a hologram that's
happening doesn't yeah there's no
built-in meaning it's like this super
feminine the only truth is that it's all
subjective and d d d it's like bypass
fear I I I'm so concerned for myself I
don't want to be in danger and it's like
deep identification with the body
masquerading as spirituality but
spirituality is what's the honest like
what's most honest and I actually like
that better than the word spirituality
if I if I have to teach yeah if I have
to teach what's most spiritual it's
going to be what's most honest honest
and and that comes back to the truth
setting us free yeah and I teach the
three levels of Truth telling which is
like I'm getting I'm telling the truth
with me and me what's actually going on
in here what am I afraid of what am I
repressing and then can I tell those
truths to my most intimate relationships
which is going to bring up it's like
where the rubber meets the road yeah and
then can I tell that truth to the world
and if I can do that it's like me
standing on a mountain top and everyone
seeing every thought every experience
I've ever had and that's Liberation and
it's either going to scare the [__] out
of you or excite you yeah so same thing
it's like the truth of that moment is
oh this old lady and her her bag being
stolen is is is a person in in
ignorance believing that in lack and
like his only way to feel powerful to
feel abundant is to take and steal and
that's going to cause him suffering for
the rest of his life of course the lady
as well but he's going to remain in
suffering so for me to end that like do
what I can to end that but then
demonstrate the truth to him that's the
evolutionary impulse like that's right
that's the most loving thing to do I'll
tell this quick story I was in London
one time and I'm in this park and um I
hear this woman screaming help help he's
stealing my
baby and I'm with my girlfriend at the
time we're having a little picnic and I
can't see this woman I just there's just
a hillside I know she's on the other
side of the hill and without even
thinking I just Sprint and I just get on
to the top of this hill and I see what's
happening and this guy like three women
including her like four and he's pulling
the baby out of her arms and it's not
too violent cuz the baby's so little
it's like they're trying to be careful
but also kind of trying like wrestling
over this baby and I have this moment
where it felt like a lifetime you know
of a pause even though it was probably 3
or 4
seconds and my animal brain said go in
and get him in a in a rear naked choke
it's like my Jiu-Jitsu days it's like I
can choke him out in five five seconds
it's fine and I had all this whole image
of me doing that and in that version my
heart's pounding and there's so much
adrenaline cuz I'm like I'm going to
have to put this guy
down and then something Dawns on me I
mean it felt like there were 10,000
angels at my back and it was like he
needs the love yeah right now right so
go in and stop this yes and give him
love yes and so I went up and I put my
hand on his back and I said you're not a
bad
guy I know you're only doing this and
this was like I couldn't plan this this
was just coming through me yeah and I
was like I know you're only doing this
because you really care CU I started to
gather it was a custody battle thing
right so it was like that you because
you really love your daughter
if you didn't care you wouldn't care
yeah
exactly and I get that you're really
angry and I'm going to stay here until
you're ready to talk and I put my and he
goes you keep your hand on my back I'm
going to hit you I said hit me hit me
I'm not going anywhere and I just I'm G
to hit you I'm going to hit you I'm
going to hit you and I just okay and I
just keep my hand on him and I'm just
following him he's kind of pacing and
they start to leave and he kind of calms
down he looks at
me and he's like looking down kind of
ashamed and and I said look at me and he
looked up and I
said um if your daughter was of age and
could see you right now is this what
you'd want to teach her beautiful and he
goes looks down 10 seconds maybe a
silence and he just looks up and goes
thank you and walks off yeah that's
great and I sat there like what just
happened I felt so
used by God
right and this like layer of like I'm so
[__] protected if I say yes to what's
true even if someone wants to punch me
in the face and is threatening me like
if my devotion to what's true is
stronger to their Devotion to what's not
true right they'll attune to the energy
I won't attune to them yeah and it was
like can I be a stand for that
yes
yeah oh it's such a good one [__] such a
good
one it's like being
so
aligned impenetrably aligned mhm that
nothing can pop up that would change
that and and also the popup would then
be morphing if it's right be morphing to
that alignment within themselves yeah
it's power over Force it's classic
Hawkins yeah it takes so much to not be
absorbed into that field because it's so
powerful and eventually when you're in
that field either someone has to run
away desperately and double down which
takes so much energy yeah yeah or they
completely depolarize and
just join
right nice yeah
gez I mean there's so many ways to uh
continue pulling and playing on on this
I want to I want to wrap because of the
upcoming call that yeah
um let's actually
show
um we have uh we have Brandon sight here
we have
uh we have some of his uh integrated
self- inquiry somatic inquiry content
also you can go check
out his current offerings
testimonials you can see what it's like
to work with him these links are all in
the bio below also in the description
he's got really good content on on
Instagram also for you to check
out a lot of these memes are just crack
me up they're so good man I love these
oh
um there just also like a lot of really
good uh direct uh pointings at things
like uh the middle way or ways to like
liberate contractions and so here's also
YouTube so yeah all of this is in the in
the description to go check out um
um let's
see yeah I mean any other closing
closing
remarks nothing's really coming yeah I
feel like we're we're we're stumbling
into very powerful like brotherhoods
right now 100% yeah I do I would mention
that there's this um it's part of this
the the journey in God you know journey
to God journey in God journey in God
being the process of continuous
integration and where is the truth of
what I
found in God not being lived in my life
and like that's it I'll use this as a
metaphor it's like I go to God and I I
find what I'm looking for and then I
bring it into my life relationships
business and that looks like in in
business and art and creation it looks
like
inspiration in relationships it looks
like love in existing in nature it looks
like Beauty right so it's like I'm
continuously that's my game of the game
and there's something really important
right now around the Battle of the Sexes
the men and women and coming back it's
so interesting to these very traditional
roles without the Dogma yeah through the
grounded understanding of we have
biological bodies still right that have
proclivity that I don't really control
you know I can't undo my attraction to a
female I can't go okay turn off I'm
discovering that I'm discovering
uh uh the bo my
body's pull
into Union or to procreation or whatever
it might be and so it's so before it
might be might have been considered just
not spiritual because it's so gross you
know gross in terms of like dents and or
Earthly yeah right but I think that's
like this this new form of grounded
spirituality where it's like let's
actually go all in on the earth yeah
exactly let's go all in like the body I
think that's why I've been dra drawn to
German new medicine as well with like
actually the more I embrace the body and
life that that that is the most
spiritual thing to do love it and that
might look like something so simple in
I'll just use the gender War for example
it's like you have feminism and the the
masculinization of women the
masculinization or the feminization of
men and with the promise on both sides
that there's more freedom in that way of
being right the women it's like if you
become this badass boss babe whatever
you know uh uh climb the corporate
ladder like you're going to be filling
the blank just another form of seeking
another form of materialism play out and
then there's a version of that for men
that they're taking on and none of this
is new on the archetypal level it's just
another form of
seeking but in the undoing of it what
we're starting to see is this like
Renaissance of remembering oh there's a
natural way that these bodies and the
strengths that are advantageous to just
living a a very ordinary existence
there's strengths in either in both of
us that when put together work like
nature work like Synergy work like the
trees and the bushes and the animals and
the water yes and I'm
loving investigating that yeah and
playing in that right now of like oh
this is actually really important and
anything in the way of my own process of
self-discovery what does this look like
for me truthfully and honestly not
because not a spiritual ideal not some
political like point of view that I was
fed but like what is being a
man look like and feel like to
me
and where before it was
like that's why would I Consciousness is
not a man it's not a woman like and I
and it's and it's like you have to go
there to then come into the grounded
reality without looking for some sort of
like salvation through it you're just
looking for what's true for you what
feels yes
totally in integrity and in alignment
and um yeah it's like there been this
like redefining of masculinity for me
over the last maybe eight months that
has been really fun right right yeah
like unwinding everything that's built
up on top of this pure Consciousness and
then from that being able to integrate
into the body into its Partnerships
unions all kinds of things and then just
watching how that is way more creatively
powerful MH mhm
yeah
and and also that like there are certain
things that I feel like have been
conditioned purposely by
um quote the for forgetting like the
kind of that's a toxic gas of forgetting
right right
and uh and one of the most powerful ones
that is showing up more and more as with
Father fatherly discipline of like hey
wake up is that you can't just be
leaking your own Sexual Energy
everywhere right right you that's like
the most powerful force in the whole
Cosmos and you're just like fap fap fap
fap over here subscribe to this only
fans thing like whatever like oh we can
[__] on the third date whatever no
problem like has no repercussions even
though I really love you or whatever
like
like Madness yeah yeah Madness and then
you wonder why there's no secure
attachment then then you wonder why
nobody can get married and last long in
marriage and have 3 6 12 kids that are
all awake children right like like Jedi
like like it's just you could you talk
about it but you can't manifest it
because there are certain toxic gases
that are still built up and show yeah
and it's this um with this Sexual Energy
piece it's
like you will wear rose-colored glasses
most often because you're dealing with
the most powerful energy in existence
and if you haven't integrated and and
had a level of maturity to handle that
responsibly you're going to feel
oxytocin and call it
love I'm in love Yeah and in that
Yearning For Love which and through the
oxytocin from sex it's like it's such a
power powerful biological bonder you
will look over often not always but most
people they'll look over tons of red
flags they'll falter on their own values
probably because they don't even know
them but so much will get put under the
rug just keep giving me this I'll do
whatever it takes for this feeling and
it's called being ruled by your feelings
and when men enter that space which is
like what we've been encouraged to do by
Society it's like be more in your
feelings which they're pointing to
something that's true yeah we need to be
willing to be vulnerable and honest and
if that makes us cry then we have to be
willing to fully go there but if we
start following the well this just feels
good so I'm a yes to it we become
pleasure addicts and we're not actually
Discerning we're not cording we're not
yeah yeah exactly there's no discipline
there's no wait let's have a a space
where we can actually determine if we're
compatible without the rose-colored
glasses on all of these other levels
because at the end of the day the sexual
act is
it's .1% of the time it really is and
it's it's such an access point to
intimacy yes it creates life and it's
not in of itself it's not doesn't create
intimacy people can have sex and not be
intimate right so it's like man to
remove that for a period of time where
there's so there's an attraction and
you're you're that's that's why I like
what the Christians point to wait till
marriage for sex it's not that that
needs to be an arbitrary rule it's that
they're pointing to like a sobriety of
like am I in this for the right reason
perfect yeah exactly a sobriety of those
tox tox tox
nauseous G gases uh and that that that
sobriety giving you the ability to look
on all of these levels of compatibility
and relatability and yeah everything
everything it's so juicy it's so juicy
and it's yeah it's not like you said
it's not is filtering through uh must
get sexual intercourse yeah yeah yeah
exactly
yeah oh it's so funny okay uh okay yeah
we should we should wrap so oh my gosh
so good so good here here we go like
this is what we're feeling so much as
this new frequency like we're fully in
our power fully in our sovereignty in
Balance fully in balance and then we
come together as equal brothers and
sisters from this place and co-create
this new world Paradigm all the healing
that needs to happen all these new light
cities all of this free energy basic
needs abundance all these things like
like this is it like this is the Anchor
Point this is the Well Point this is
like the root fully as a sword in the
center of the earth like let's go from
here and like yeah it's so yeah hell
yeah hell yeah yeah yeah man it's so
beautiful like having you here live in
Austin it's really good yeah really good
so fun yeah love this love this work
love this conversation and yeah it's
like when two or more gather he is there
you know and it's like I I think it's
exponential it's not two and two is four
it's two and two is 16 yeah when there's
that alignment and synchronicity and
yeah yeah exactly and um if you guys
want to there's all the links in the
description below uh checking out
Brandon's work in more detail and also
um if the content brought you value of
course like subscribe if you haven't yet
comment below with what you think
resonated the most and share the content
also to people that you feel like it
would resonate with and um I'm just
really looking forward to continuing to
play together and yeah and create and
yeah yeah likewise bro super cool all
right much love thank you so much for
tuning in and we will see you soon
bye-bye everyone